aerial photography used to be reserved
only for professionals but as
smartphones have changed the way people
take pictures so have new travel
opportunities lights and views that were
once almost impossible to get are
becoming routine and that's making for a
spectacular surge of aerial photography
nationwide Jeff Glor explains looking up
across America's largest city it is
impossible to beat the views unless you
try looking down from Central Park to
One World Trade and the Statue of
Liberty New York is even more impressive
from elevation
[Music]
[Applause]
fly nyam is one of the businesses taking
advantage of a rapidly rising aerial
photography market by offering tours
without the doors Tim Orr is the
company's CEO oh because today people
don't just want to look at great photos
they want to take them themselves it's
an experience the city actually is an
experience from the air nothing like it
when flying ion launched in 2013 it was
geared to professionals all of this for
you or a lot of it is social media 100%
of it is pretty much social media we
were posting our photographs just
sharing what we see with the world and
it was coming back tenfold how can I do
this I want to do that where did you get
that picture and it just the light bulb
went off and it was like I don't see why
you can't come either so we opened the
doors and people started jumping on
board or is quickly expanded to Las
Vegas Miami San Francisco and Los
Angeles this makes it accessible to
everybody you buy a seat you go up when
you want to and you take your photos you
post it on Instagram or Facebook and
your friends are going whoa I want to do
that everybody's a photographer today
it's true it's that bad no I think it's
great it is a long way from where Alex
mcclain started 42 years ago McClain has
published 11 books on aerial photography
over his career I would go up and go
shoot and come back get my film back
three days later it was all overexposed
and you wanted to shoot yourself it was
really expensive
now you good to see how you're doing
right on the spot it's just it's it's
very simple his views of landscapes
range from tobacco farms two rows of cut
flowers to b-52 boneyards but the first
thing I had to do was learn how to fly
that was tough in itself because I was
terrified of flying
we joined him for a recent flight
outside Boston in a Cessna 172 we flew
over the famed Walden Pond MacLean
pointed out the water level is so low
it's nearly surrounded by beach much of
his work today focuses on the
environment you know the most immediate
threat in so many different ways
everywhere you look you can see climate
issues at play
you know from agriculture coastal areas
he virus virus that we have now Google
is also in the game earth lets users
really explore the entire planet in 3d
now in an update you can trace the path
of hurricanes and see how our world has
been affected it is such an unique
vantage point to be able to see a place
from that altitude and to kind of
understand more of how the earth is
connected between the oceans and
mountains and different land masses and
there's really no way to do that without
having that kind of a perspective this
year Google also added a Voyager feature
part tourist guide part teacher you can
sewer everything from the Kennedy Space
Center to lost civilizations and if
Google Earth is a place to get lost
Google Voyager is a place to learn
voyagers a bit of your guide to help you
sort of navigate some of these places
and to have that kind of ability to spin
the globe zoom into a place that you
think might be interesting and go along
for the ride and see where it takes you
it's addicting it is a little bit
addicting
it also doesn't cost anything so the
beauty of it is it could you know see
all these places from wherever is most
comfortable for you all this said or
says the most important place to capture
a memory is still in the mind are there
times when people are so focused on
taking pictures that they're not paying
attention to what they're actually
seeing with their eyes really they're
shootings
fast trying to capture everything
sometimes we actually tell them they put
the camera down look at what you're
seeing the picture in the memories is
actually sometimes a lot more valuable
for CBS this morning Saturday Jeff Glor
New York I don't like flying out of
LaGuardia but the best moment yes is
when you get to fly over the city you
get an incredible view of Manhattan it's
breathtaking
yeah really worth going up there